foreign
take a look outside
did you know that they call callisto the
dead moon
dead
just like you would have been if i
hadn't fished you out of that wreck
so whatever you're holding on to right
there
that's your old life you gotta let that
go
[Music]
i'm just trying to give you a chance
at rebirth
[Music]
i just love that last part
gives me chills every time
[Applause]
welcome
to your new home
[Music]
that's right we know what you wanted to
see and joining me now glenn schofield
striking this is glenn uh first of all
congratulations this game looks
absolutely incredible and i gotta say
the fact that you have built this team
this studio new ip shipping this
december all in kovid blows me away so
congratulations yeah thanks man uh
thanks for having us i really do
appreciate it jeff um and you know for a
second just give me a second
you know i want to thank you uh for all
you've done for the game industry uh all
these years man i i think i've known you
like 16 17 years now and uh
um you've been an ambassador
um you've amplified new games new
studios and uh i i just wanted to thank
you i really do appreciate it thank you
it's not about me it's about you guys
yeah i know i appreciate that thank you
so much and yeah it's so fun to do these
shows and to show this game so people
saw the trailer but what i'm so excited
today is that you just brought a raw
gameplay sequence this game is in
development and people are gonna be
blown away i think when they see it but
tell us a bit about what are we gonna
see today yeah we got a couple minutes
of uh like you said like we're all game
play um it's two segments in the first
half of the game uh one is a med bay
another one is a power station and
you're gonna see uh some
new enemies some brutality some uh just
about everything we we're showcasing a
new weapon called the grip it's a like a
gravity gun but it picks up the enemies
and it shoves them into giant fans it
rips them apart it's great and uh and
then check out the uh
the nice ending we have where we uh you
know we usually will kill our main
character jacob and in a very unique way
and uh
uh just for a second i i want to thank
the team man like you said through covid
through everything else the dedication
the hard work uh you guys are amazing
thank you very much oh well glenn i
gotta say again you know what you guys
are shipping this year this looks like a
world-class next-gen game uh it's it's
rare that teams are bringing something
out like this this year and
let's let the footage speak for itself
schofield striking distance here it is
the first game play of the callisto
protocol
what's going on
uh
oh
[Music]
foreign
so
foreign
oh